biden flew into geneva for the biggest
meeting of his presidency so far
a test of his diplomatic agility
standing up to a foe
while at the same time trying to rebuild
a strategic relationship
that's deeply strained security is tight
across the city
such is the way when russia and america
come together for a summit like this
mr putin won't arrive until a few hours
before the lunchtime meeting
here at the villa lagrange but the
controversies he carries
precede him alexey navalny putin's
political critic
poisoned then imprisoned in russia he
will be a focus for the americans
his death in jail wood biden said beyond
putin
supporters were modest in numbers but
expect their message to be heard
he will kill anyone he will stop anyone
who tries to take this power from him
president biden brings with him support
from the nato meeting this week in
brussels he agreed red lines with fellow
leaders
that he says he will spell out for
president putin
i have met with him he's bright
he's tough and uh i have found that uh
he is a uh as they say when he used to
play ball a worthy adversary
and that adversary will bring with him
his own red lines the prospect of nato
membership for ukraine
is the biggest the context is mr putin's
2018 meeting with donald trump behind
the smiles it was a deeply
counterproductive moment for the
relationship
andre kortenov is director general of
the russian international affairs
council
and considered a kremlin insider i don't
think that
they can expect to come to any
conclusions i don't even think that
they're in a position to sign a joint
communique or any other document
unfortunately the positions of the two
sides on very fundamental problems of
global politics are are too far apart
36 years ago in this same city it was
the body language of presidents reagan
and gorbachev which the world examined
they had turned up at this seminal
meeting as cold war enemies
they came out not as friends but closer
nearly four decades on and it feels at
times as though the cold war is back and
in that context any meeting
between the two presidents is positive
diplomats on both sides are playing down
expectations it isn't about resetting
the relationship they're not there yet
this is about stabilizing what has for
some years
been a very rocky dialogue getting
through this summit with the pretense at
least of mutual respect and without any
diplomatic moments
they would be achievements in themselves